you meet somebody where
you say this guy's got a big upset man
that guy can really kill it oh my gosh
and then he says tim i just want to be
an all-star i'm good with that man i
don't care to win a championship i don't
care to be on mount rushmore i don't
care to be
one of the greatest of all if i never
make in the hall of fame i'm going to
live a happy life i'm going to be
totally okay with it
so is winning to you the individuals
level of success they want to have or is
winning to you somebody that goes out
there and says i want to find out what
my best version looks like i want to
find out how
what my capacity looks like how do you
judge it it's by the capacity okay it's
always a capacity you know
if you don't people
they look at winning and finishing
as the same those individuals that
you're talking about
they're just looking to finish they're
just looking to finish their career
they're like okay this is what
i got this nice house i'm finished over
here i made the nba or made the end of
that that's finishing and a lot of
people to that
like they feel like if they finish
they've won
these individuals it's a completely
different it's a completely different
level
so you have individuals that go out and
run marathons you know
if you compete at the highest level and
you're
a person that just runs marathon the
chances of you winning that marathon
are pretty much zero but you're going to
finish that marathon
but being able to finish that marathon
puts you in a mindset
to win at something else
so there's always what's next what's
next what's the next thing that's going
on you know we talk about what kobe one
of his biggest lines
is you know don't rest in the middle
rest at the end winners rest at the end
when you talk about fit people that just
want to finish
just what you said they rest in the
middle you know
for the longest time i was people ask
the question you know what's success to
you what's
you know one of those questions what's
your favorite success oh the key to
success
and i've heard a million different
things you know marry the right person
you know faith hard work save money make
money
read books you know do all the stuff
that we hear from a bunch of different
people
to me it was a alignment
where you know your values and
principles match
the lifestyle you're living so and not
worrying about what others think about
you but for you you spend a lot of time
around mike
mj and you spend a lot of time around uh
kobe
you've spent a lot of time on a lot of
other guys you know duane
pat riley you know whether it's barkley
you've spent a lot of time around these
guys
but if mike's sitting right here and we
asked kobe okay
what's the definition definition of
success to those two guys what would you
say their answers would be
well in the book kobe said he said
winning is everything
it's everything all right
and you sit here and you talk talk to
mike whatever kobe would say
mike would have to one-up them because
they're still
the competition never stops it's always
about
what's next what can i what can i win
more at
you know both those individuals you know
obviously kobe's not with us anymore
but both those individuals
the competition and the desire
and the feeling of winning even though
they were done with playing
manifested into something else you know
mj the most successful sneaker brand out
there
all right owning a team tequila business
um in the sports gambling business he's
in
all those things he's in all those
things
all right so the competition never stops
with kobe it was like i'm gonna win an
oscar
go out and win an oscar writing
children's writing children's book he
was literally
his goal he would his plan
was to take over hollywood he was like i
owned la on the basketball court
and now i want to own
la he wanted to take that was his
winning thing take the basketball out of
it
everyone knows i own l.a on the
basketball court
and we talked about this he goes
own la
own la and if you look at the paths he
was going through
that's what he that's what he was doing
that's what he was that was his that was
his
next definition of winning i wouldn't
bet against the guy
i would not bet against him we had him
over at the event
and i uh uh gave him a couple gifts i
gave him a script i gave him a script i
think by
star wars and was signed it was the
original script and
you know he was fascinated by that like
when we were having a conversation in
the back all he was talking about was
storytelling storytelling storytelling
storytelling it was like an obsession
that he had so here's here's a different
question for you so
the feeling of winning obviously is
a million times better than you think
it's going to feel like yeah surprising
it's just a ridiculous feeling i go
there
movies do very well because in the
storyline somebody ends up winning and
the audience comes and says oh my gosh
what a great underdog
story i love this movie pursuit of
happiness i love
watching you know invincible the guy
ends up playing for you know the jets a
regular bartender guy i love
watching this guy winning i love
watching all these different things
i think he played for the eagles uh
eagles you're right philadelphia that's
right i said yes
the story is about the city of
philadelphia you're right so you you see
all these different
uh movies do well because we see
somebody winning right we see somebody
winning
why don't most people subscribe to
wanting to find out what their capacity
looks like
and go at the highest level they enjoy
the story but why don't you want to
commit to it
because they rather participate why they
they want it they want to just protest
they want to participate
in somebody else's win
because that's where their euphoria
comes from because they want to see
what they know what winning feels like
but what it takes to go down that
unforgiving
race to winning
they don't want to do because it's just
too
hard so they rather stay in the middle
they rather stay because that's where
majority of the comfort is
it's in the middle everybody wants to be
seen
until it's time to be seen winning
in order to win you have to be seen
and once you become and once everyone
can see you you become a target
you become a target so everybody
everyone has their perception of winning
as this glory this glorious thing and it
is
and it is but the book talks about
everything that goes along that path
and what winning will bring you and it's
not
always what you anticipate to be
you can look at yourself yeah you can
look at my say you look at any success
you can look at any successful person
any person that's going
for more wins that's going for their
full potential
and they sit back and you have times and
you're just like
why am i doing this why am i do why am i
why am i doing this and then it may hit
you for a split second
but then you become i know exactly why
i'm doing this
all right those other people when they
say why am i doing this
that why wins with the people that
continue to win
that why doesn't exist like i know why
i'm doing this
so do you think those who say well you
know i don't know if it's something
worth me paying the price is it the fear
of the criticism
do they know that they're going to get
that kind of criticism or they don't
know that
it's just i don't think it's worth me
paying the price to get this because
what if it doesn't work out and what if
i can't do it is it a belief thing
is it they don't have the level of
obsession is it they don't have the chip
is it they don't have the point to want
to prove to somebody
what what what would you point out it's
all the above okay got it it's all the
oversee what everybody's trying to
figure out
what what's the you get this question
all the time i get this all
what's the one thing boy i wish it was
that simple
that's the one thing so everybody what's
the one thing to success
what's the one thing to your success
what's the one thing to making it what's
the one thing to winning
man if it was that easy everybody be
doing it you know people
they have everyone has
and this drives me crazy this drives me
this drives me absolutely crazy and i
was told by
another individual that the one thing i
have to do
in my um in my teachings is i have to
i have to do steps i have to do steps i
have to give people
five steps 10 steps so forth
and i'm not a step person i i'm just not
it's not something that's worked for me
it's not something that's worked for the
individuals i know it simplifies things
and helps people out
but when you look at the the road to
winning
people look at you and they're like
you're a success
all right but your road has so many more
steps
those steps are infinite sometimes you
get to see them
sometimes you don't sometimes
they're there other times they're wobbly
and you don't know if that next step is
going to be there but you have enough
belief in yourself to say i know it's
there i'm going to take i'm going to
take that
i'm going to take that step i may miss
the step i may fall i may
get i may get scraped that step may go
in a quick stance
but i know there's another step i know
it i believe inside me
that there's another step that i have to
take that somebody else isn't making me
take and you continue to take those
those steps are
infinite winning is infinite those steps
are infinite and you're deaf people
don't want to continue to take those
steps
i don't care what kind of shape an
individual's in the greatest
athletes all right as much training as
they ever do
if you've ever had to run up a flight of
steps
it's hard it's extreme it's extremely
difficult
all right so when people say there's
there's the there's 10 easy steps or you
know there's five steps of greatness or
this
those steps to me are their steps to me
are infinite and even when you put that
plan
out there people aren't willing to even
take those five steps so if you like
this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye